hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sorry and calm and today I'm going to
demonstrate how to withdraw medication
from an ampule as a nurse you're gonna
be required to withdraw medications from
glass ampules and you'll want to know
how to actually break this ampule
without getting hurt and how to remove
the liquid medication that is inside of
the ampule so you'll want to confirm
that you have the right medication and
it's the right dose you're giving it at
the right time via the right route to
the right patient then you'll want to
perform hand hygiene and gather your
supplies you will need your ampule which
contains your medication you also need a
syringe that has its own needleless or
needle device that you will use to
actually administer the medication also
you will need a filter straw these come
in various sizes 4 inch and 1 and 3/4 we
are using a 1 and 3/4 because of the
size of our ampule so pick the size
accordingly and just like its name says
it's a filter straw so we're going to
actually attach this device onto our
syringe whenever we withdraw the
medication out of the glass ampule
because it's going to help prevent us
from possibly withdrawing in any like
glass particles that could go to our
patient then we need a gauze because
we're gonna use the gauze to actually
assist us in breaking this glass ampule
and you need some alcohol prep to help
you clean the neck of the ampule before
you break it first what you want to do
is you want to inspect the ampule make
sure it's not cracked or has any
imperfections also you want to make sure
that the solution is clear it doesn't
have any particles floating around in it
or it's discolored then what you want to
do is you want to make sure that all the
liquid is down in the body of the ampule
because sometimes it likes to collect up
here in the head so what you want to do
is you just want to hold it steady a
little bit and just lightly tap or flick
the top of the ampule and the fluid will
go down into the body then you want to
take your alcohol prep and you want to
clean the
neck of ampule just to help prevent
contamination whenever you go to break
that
so we clean it and then let it
completely dry so while we're letting
our ampule dry we're going to connect
our syringe to our filter straw and
we've already opened our packaging so
what we're gonna do is we're going to
just unscrew the syringe from its
original needleless device and leave it
in the packaging because we're actually
going to use this device to administer
the medication remember you don't
administer it with filtered straw and
you're gonna take the syringe and just
screw it on to the filter straw and
leave it in the packaging until we're
actually ready to withdraw the
medication now we're ready to break open
the ampule and many of these glass
ampules have a scored area that actually
make breaking the ampule a lot easier so
if you have that that's great so you're
gonna take your clean gauze and you're
going to wrap it around the head and the
neck of the ampule and whenever we go to
break it we're gonna break it this way
like in a snapping motion so the broken
parts are away from our body so we don't
get cut so here we go we're gonna wrap
it around the head the neck and we're
just going to snap it off then you will
have a broken piece of the head and the
neck and you want to actually throw this
in the sharps container and throw away
your gauze now we're going to withdraw
the medication out of the ampule so
we're going to get our syringe with its
filter straw and we're going to insert
the straw inside the ampule now you do
not have to inject air inside the
ampules so make sure your ampule is on a
steady flat surface and you're holding
it with your fingers to keep it steady
I'm gonna go in in the middle and then
you're going to which all the prescribed
amount of solution so the physician
ordered about one cc here so we're gonna
pull back until we hit one cc but we're
gonna go a smidge over it because we
have to remove the air from the syringe
and then we'll squirt out the excess of
medication then we're going to remove
our filter straw and we're going to turn
the syringe upright and slightly flick
it to get the air bubbles out want to
get them all out they can be stubborn
sometimes so get it and then you're
gonna push up slightly on your plunger
and a little bit of medication can
sometimes strip out that's okay and
you're going to push out to the
prescribed amount and then you're going
to remove the filters straw and you're
going to dispose of the filters straw
and the glass ampule into the sharps
container after you do that you're going
to connect the syringe to its original
administration device so just take it
screwed on there and then you can leave
it in the protective covering until
you're ready to administer the
medication thank you so much for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos